it is great to welcome back to the
program today dr. Christopher DeCarlo
who's an award-winning philosopher
educator and author of this the latest
book on critical thinking called so you
think you can think tools for having
intelligent conversations and getting
along it's great to have you back on
good to be here always a pleasure so a
common question I get from viewers when
I take live calls is I have family
members who believe this or who believe
that and I want to know how it is that I
should confront them and usually my
answer is that depends on how willing
you are to ruin the relationship in
other words there there's ways to do
this more lightly with a Socratic method
of questioning and sort of gentle
inquiry into how one formed their
beliefs there's ways to have these
conversations much more pointedly and
aggressively it will give me your sort
of 30,000 foot view on how some of these
often difficult conversations can be
approached right so in this book I talk
about spectral discussions and what I
mean by that is if an issue can be
polarized and many of them are you know
polarized
take for example gun control something
to which your country deals with on a
daily basis you know what you do is you
you look at the extremes of that what
what should we do well allow all guns
everywhere no matter what you can drive
a tank to work you know you can do all
that kind of stuff the other end of the
spectrum no guns whatsoever you know all
that kind of thing and then start by
determining where on the spectrum the
two discussants lie like where are you
and then see how how fact you know
polarized those views are and then try
to imagine is there any common area
between those two positions and what are
those so you know start with what is
your argument what is it that you
believe allow me to understand that have
each other say what their arguments are
back to each other it's that we call it
steel Manning you're probably familiar
with
yeah rather than straw Manning the other
person's argument and making it a
mockery you really want to say okay so
let me get this straight is this what
you believe and then you lay it on the
line then they can do the same now you
you know where you are on that spectrum
and now you can talk about you know
would we be able to change our views is
there any evidence or any information
that might draw us closer together
so I'm finding that this method is
becoming very helpful
yes Oh Peter Boghossian has described
that what would cause you to change your
mind if it were the case the the
feasibility test to see if someone is
even open to to re-examining their their
beliefs now when it comes to I mean just
to pick something that has come up
recently here in the United State and by
the way so Christopher is Canadian and
that's why he said your country and just
so people understand the context here of
the discussion here in the United States
there's a big controversy now around
statues Confederate era statues and
statues reminiscent of slavery and one
of the critiques I had of a lot of the
conversations that are happening are
that the conversations in media are
often only represented by extreme views
meaning you should never take a statue
down and on the other hand take down
George Washington because he owns like
these extremes whereas most people
probably would be able to have a more
nuanced conversation like well listen
there was an era where everybody had
slaves and what we should look at is
maybe more whether the individual is
known for promoting slavery versus
whether they're really right so that
that seems to be a big part of the
conversation that often the
conversations are only happening in
extremes yeah and and it's unfortunate
right that and then the media is
partially to blame because they love the
extremes right you've got a great story
you get more clicks you get more hits
you get more viewers whatever it is you
know we were fascinated with the the
confrontation as it were we've lost the
capacity to appreciate nuance and it
looks like we're in a baby out with the
bathwater kind of
movement right now where you know no
matter what good a person has done in
their life if during those times they
were involved in other types of
activities which are now deemed quite
reprehensible or horrific or horrible or
you know whatever it is then everything
that that person might have accomplished
that was good is ignored because they
were involved with these other you know
kind of nefarious or or questionable
types of moral activities and we need to
have the conversation around these
statues to look at them and say you know
what good if any has has this person
done for Humanity and what are the bad
things and use it use these as teachable
moments and if if they if they are
indeed offensive for whatever reasons
should we just put them in museums then
and then use them as it for educational
purposes to say yes this person did X Y
& Z but you know what they also did this
as well you know I teach at Ryerson
University
Edgerton Ryerson was responsible for the
the school systems that put a lot of
Aboriginal kids took him away from their
parents and put him in these schools
what's called the residential school
problem but his statue is still standing
at Ryerson University and I'm wondering
if it's just a matter of time before you
know people think you know that's got to
come down as well so he did a lot of
great things for education but he he
also did some not-so-great things it's
the world is more complicated if if we
hold our hero's you know those in high
esteem too high they have that much
farther to fall when we realized
nobody's perfect and and and you know we
are a nuanced difficult species at best
here in the United States we're
experiencing the deadly repercussions I
don't think that's an exaggeration of a
critical thinking gap or lack when it
comes to coronavirus and this applies to
understanding how masks work this comes
to you know ideas like if we tested less
we'd have fewer cases I mean there's no
shortage of sort of examples what do you
make of the way in which this is failing
in the United States
is it education is it culture is it
economics I mean like where do we start
yeah there are so many systems involved
here right and some of the work I'm
doing in critical thinking is something
I call relational systemics which is to
look at all the systems that are
involved that interplay and and cause
people to think the way they do at a
given time in history yeah we can look
at the education systems for sure but
you got to understand you know memes can
kill you I mean I've written about you
know mimetic equilibrium and the idea
that when you get comfortable with a set
of ideas it doesn't matter if they run
counter to reality
you know if ideology can outweigh
reality and in so doing you mentioned it
weaponized ignorant you you talk about
the idea that the mask has become a
symbol of oppression in your country for
some people and that is absolutely
bizarre for the rest of the world to
look at that and think you're missing a
really important point here and that is
this is a public health issue it's not
as it's a political it has nothing to do
with politics we want everybody to
survive we don't care what your politics
is we don't want you to die we don't
want you to you know feel discomfort or
to spread the disease any further so you
know that is a horrific example of
weaponizing ignorance and using it as a
tool or a symbolic representation of a
political movement so some people in my
audience feel very strongly and I've
even said this before that if critical
thinking and epistemology and philosophy
were a part of everybody's schooling
starting probably around seventh-grade
age 12 that a lot of this that we're
seeing would be short-circuited and
preempted altogether but then I do get
pushback from people who maybe people
who work in school systems that are
teaching these things to some degree
saying the problem is bigger than that
and you have to understand that teachers
can only do so much anyway and a lot of
it is what's going on at home and what's
going on in culture and what's going on
in the media so what's the lowest
hanging fruit where do we start to turn
this around and what could have the best
if the biggest effect most quickly right
I've been lobbying governments here in
Canada and have had
success with trying to get critical
thinking taught at the first of all at
the high school system you know very
well David that critical thinking
teaches people how to think right we its
the tools that allow them to better
understand information and then to
determine you know the acceptability of
that information and whether or not they
should act on that information and I do
very much believe if we can get critical
thinking into the schools as early as
possible I I believe seven and eight is
probably the right time to start to
introduce it to get it going I think
would be much more difficult for people
to then say I don't care what science
says you know my leader maintains X yes
because it empowers people critical
thinking isn't just something you do
it's what you live and we have to make
that a part of people's lives so that it
becomes almost reflexive it almost
becomes a reflex action when information
is is presented in a particular way that
is false to the way in which the natural
world actually functions and that's
where we need to start we need to start
at those those middle aged grades you
know seven and eight and all the way
through high school for sure from from
the standpoint of the virus and what
you've observed what if we do a sort of
analyses analysis of fallacious thinking
or fallacious assertions what are the
main fallacies that you're seeing in the
context of discussions about cases viral
spread contagion treatment masks etc I
mean just get you know if you have a
couple bullet points on that right well
first of all it's the it's the
misinformation and disinformation we
have to stop and that's you know what
was at Wayne settle I can make itself
around the world you know halfway around
the world while the truth is putting its
shoes on or whatever so once mints
misinformation gets out there we need to
focus on how to combat that quickly and
effectively and to me there's no easy
solution for that social media has
gotten to the point where influencers
are being trusted more than you know
scientists yeah
and right once we get to that level then
I think it it it becomes paramount that
science and the influencers if possible
the scientists and the influencers could
somehow work together right what's
horrifying about that is some attempts
were made like that for example doctor
foul she did a bunch of live streams
with folks like Stefan curry the NBA
basketball player and trying to sort of
bring it's just I don't know if it was
too little or too late but you've got
you know a political movement which is
listening more to a game show host than
an infectious disease doctor I know I
just don't know it's I it just feels
like we're living in an alien's thought
experiment it just seems so weird what
what what's happening right to to see
this occur and to know what the truth is
and I'm not talking about big tree big
tea metaphysical truth or anything I'm
just talking about scientific
probabilistic truth that is for the
benefit of all humankind and I really
I'm at a loss with this one in terms of
what's the best way to engage in having
the conversation like how much evidence
can be provided in order to convince
somebody that they really ought to wear
a mask right that it it's not a
political statement that you know
finally Trump wore one for the first
time I think you know the other day what
was he a Walter Reed or wherever yeah
you know it was a they basically said
you're wearing one so that that's good
somebody's got to stand up to this guy
like I don't I don't know why people
aren't but maybe that's just that cult
of personality that he has right when it
comes to statistics it's of course we
know very much about how sticks can be
shaped in order to give a the impression
of a or the opposite of a and and a lot
of it is just understanding the
mechanisms that are used what
specifically can you recommend to the
audience in order to parse statistics
for themselves like when Donald Trump
says we're testing more than anyone or
the death rate has to come down tenfold
is this a
understanding that people need or is it
more of a critical thinking
understanding both like I really do
think statistical and probabilistic
reasoning is a part of critical thinking
and it should be taught fairly early on
and I'm actually dealing with teachers
right now who have who are you know
creatively using the pandemic to teach
students about statistics and
probability it's a wonderful teachable
moment that they're using under such
hard you know conditions it's it's you
know it's like that you know the flower
emerging out of you know the the manure
kind of thing it's wonderful to see them
taking this as a teachable moment that
they can then say look you know as I say
this is a numbers game this comes down
to numbers and the better numbers we
have the more accurate we can be with
those numbers testing tracing tracking
knowing who has it knowing who doesn't
have it look until there's a vaccine
this is what we've got this is our
defense especially with a virus that has
a you know eight such a large
asymptomatic population and that's
really what we're dealing with here and
nobody really wants to address that but
the fact of the matter is we can solve a
lot of the issues if it's done
intelligently and if we have the right
numbers but we have to be together on
this in the United States if you look at
County data you see that the growth
rates of cases are significantly higher
in counties that voted for Donald Trump
relative to counties that voted for
Hillary Clinton but if we step back from
from that maybe so specifically in your
work
have there been certain groups that seem
to do better when it comes to critical
thinking than worse and I'm not talking
about genetically or anything like that
but but through cultural and education
reasons whether it's Democrats versus
Republicans or religious versus
non-religious or whatever the case may
be are there trends you've observed
that's a great question you know I mean
we we have seen that those who are more
fervently religious have a little bit
more difficult time reconciling
inconsistencies with their worldviews
but that's to be expected right
you know my my take on religion is
basically you know you can believe in
anything you want you just can't harm
people through those beliefs or harm
other species through those beliefs so
if you're so dogmatic you've reached a
point where you refuse to entertain the
possibility that you could be wrong you
see the obvious danger in that and and
there's when I look at someone like
Donald Trump there is nothing more
dangerous than blind ignorance which is
not even knowing you don't know like
that's a really dangerous epistemic
state of mine to be in and I see it
continuously and so yeah if a person is
overly dogmatic that's obviously gonna
present barriers right and then you have
to adjust your strategy for having a
conversation with that person you have
to be much more Socratic much more
gentle in your approach because the
harder you try to consider or analyze
their beliefs the more they're gonna dig
in and say you're the problem not me
what do you think will be the long-term
effect on society of of the virus I had
a conversation with a Brian Greene not
long ago and there there's sometimes
this instinct that this is really going
to change things period and Public
Health is going to be done differently
the way people greet each other is going
to change permanently I tend to go in
the direction of things sort of return
to the mean and people go back to normal
and and it's very hard to get really
long lasting change for humans where are
you on that issue I'm hopeful you know
I'm cautiously optimistic but let's face
it David my colleagues and I have been
writing to our politicians and to
politicians in China for you know over
two decades basically saying look
there's going to be a pandemic if we
don't put initiatives in place that
monitor the sale of certain types of
species of animals leave you it's just
it was just a ticking time bomb it was
not a matter of if but when and you know
a lot of them would come back and say
what we caught SARS you know we took
care of MERS we've got h1n1 got a
vaccine for h1 we're do
good job and my colleagues and I were
saying yeah until we get either a long
incubation period or people who are
asymptomatic or both and then you're not
going to be ready and they didn't listen
to that so I'm very hopeful that in the
future we are able to develop worldwide
policies for other countries in terms of
how things are done and this is not to
you know necessarily be a you know
critical of other cultures for their
lifestyles and whatnot no this is really
just a world public health issue yeah
these are just facts just facts if bats
and we know bats contain a lot of
viruses and they do jump to other
species which then can jump to humans we
need to take the science and we need to
utilize that as best as we can to make
sure this doesn't happen again or if it
does we've got measures in place that
will will stop it clear very quickly and
not allow this to occur
now that's hopeful for the future in
regards to your other questions I think
early on after people start to get
vaccinated it's gonna take a little
while for people to just start so many
how to handshake or to you know
congregate in groups or whatnot it's
it's gonna be interesting is it gonna
make a world of germaphobes
I hope not I want people to be germ
aware we need to be smart about
pathogens and and and and and I'm very
hopeful that you're you're in the Boston
area where they filmed jaws you're
probably too young to remember this but
when jaws came out there was a huge
influx of students taking marine biology
right they were majoring in marine
biology when in you know Indiana Jones
came out there was a huge influx of
pious students taking archaeology I'm
hoping after this is a huge influx of
people going into microbial ecology
which is exactly what we need we need
people to understand the
interconnectedness of the very tiny
pathogens to the rest of the world it's
really an arms race between us and
pathogens and this was a virus a
relatively weak virus you know this was
I'm not gonna say easy but
it could have been much worse oh my
goodness this could have been you know
machen if this were like an Ebola right
it would be horrific it would be you
know black death time it would be not a
good time for this planet yeah the book
is so you think you can think tools for
having intelligent conversations and
getting along we've been speaking with
the book's author dr. Christopher de
Carlo
so great to have you on I appreciate
your time once again my pleasure glad to
be here